and also I want to say something to you
Gilbert yes sir and I really mean this
from the bottom of my heart
mmm okay making me nervous don't ever
[ __ ] kalila oh say bar you say it to me
all the time though very [ __ ] nervous
you looked at me before we did the
podcast and your bedroom said hey man is
where the magic happens
yeah you're gonna cut me no no okay just
listen - [ __ ] what I said I'm sorry
don't ever become competitive with me
there's something nice
we will never compete know how we ever
compete I could feel a little bit right
that you've right yeah job right I get
competitive yeah that you might at one
point you know you know I mean that
you'll get competitive with me and I
want to tell you that I'm not competing
with you I want you to have success but
just does that never have that feeling
and if I'm imagining okay if I'm
imagining it mmm then I'm imagining it
right yoram but I love you so much that
I just want to throw out that don't ever
because whatever you need it will help
you I think here's I'm gonna defend
Gilbert for a second if he ever asks you
and he inquires about the roles that you
auditioned for if he inquires about the
process that's him just trying learning
learn from you in every way possible
that he can he's not nobody just sound
to me that right so cuz I gotta do this
movie yeah and I told him what it was
good oh yeah well I you know yeah I had
when I was too young I'm too young for
it and I'm saying that's not what he
said at all or for that other one was
literally all he said was in Swedish
inform their because you're Bobby Lee
like Who am I that's exactly what he
said it's interesting for me to see like
how a they keep its me for me it's how
they view Asians in the industry oh yeah
and he should be he should be asking you
questions and he should be gaining as
much knowledge as possible about your
process because when I you know yeah I'm
just saying I'm like Benedict
Cumberbatch you're like Tilda Swinton no
I got you yelled again throwing out
just throwing out something that you
know mean that I don't ever want to
happen it's not I'm saying I might
though how I'm just throwing it out
there just to in the universe it might
not it's probably just from if you are
already going to the same auditions that
Bobby gets the part for use that we're
now there's such a closeness but the
only reason I'm getting with them right
now is the only things I can get because
I'm Asian
like they're never right for me because
that's not my it doesn't mean but I'm
saying just that you're going to the
same you're going for the same roles
already so eventually you will Gilbert
you're extremely talented you're gonna
get up to where he is many years away
from offer land let's just put it that
way each other yes I believe it you're
so talented Gilbert I don't want to ever
don't downplay your [ __ ] and I was
gonna say to me that like if you beat me
on a roll I want to say to myself that
we're not gonna be everyone's
girlfriends well friends I mean you
you're gonna be his new obsession though
if you do if you do beat him out in a
role you know what I'm talking about
like what's role like it let's say you
beat him out in a role and you start
hash tagging like crackle or hash table
that's just more to I am but you know
that he will like secretly secretly like
brood and like hate you right the reason
why but I feel the London he just
thought it'd be a brought him up you
brought someone ask you a lot of the new
listeners don't know what DP stands for
that's it that's all I need another okay
the reason why I'm affected sometimes by
looking at de Pays social media is
because he humble rags and he also just
straight-up brags about things right
it's not humble brag all brags okay all
brag about things that why would you
brag about that is what the question I
have in my head purge it right and stuff
that I have feared that I would ever
even come close to doing he does yeah I
mean and it bothers me in that sense you
know mean that like for instance
what are you trying to I'm just a said
no we're not scratch the whole this
whole conversation wait my cats might be
safe
no no why don't you say that why'd you
bring it up then I didn't bring [ __ ] up
I was talking about Gilbert it should
clerical and when you said crackle I
mean it went to DP and once I went to DP
then it brought up something I'm on
medication
what do we have time wise we're at 47 no
we're not there at all we're not doing
well
[Music]